ん
[音楽]
これで
やっとドラゴンボールがならくそっ
これ
突然パチスロでおかけして意識不明になってしまったところだかを蘇らせることが
できる
よし
行くぞ
ビデオああシェラー
思うおまお前がしろかー
hey
me
[音楽]
ん
stay ん
られる願いが一つだけ
性能山
どうぞ買おう
蘇らせてください
ブーブーっ
ポッ
どんな感速い3おっ蘇ったのか
よみがえってみてずんかあああああわあ
という感じですねそのたら本ボールであればこの後
願い肝心だと泥棒フォルランもキュットって世界各国に飛び散ってってもう一度
ドラゴンボールを田中さんは言えば言ってるんですけれども
実際私思ったんですよ泥ゴール酸素大変なんですよで悟空バブルだがいいんだからまだ
マシだったものの
我々普通の人間だとドラゴンレーダー
おっけないんで gps もついてるんですかそう
その中世界各地で7を集めるのもあった絶対たぶん無理なんでちょっとでも捧げますで
この家の中に取らもうボールがならと繋がってても集めの難しいジャンプがあるって
言うんです
まあ誰か来疲れ様ですけどねそうでそこであなたを呼びました
どんなもの福祉がうまいので今回ちょっとかねニコッ
いらねードラゴリー7校願い使っちゃってたんで飛んで行くはずなんですけどもそんな
方がもしこの部屋だったらやった分世界各社まず無理だしなんならこの僕の住んでる
部屋の中になぜ怖セラ貼ってってわけわかんないとこに隠されても見つけれるのか
難しいと思ってます
西フェイクを誘うたいですからねほんとに最近開けたときそれから個分の空
に小さい花ですからね実際ドラゴンボール現実的に考えて難しいと思うので75マジで
難しいと思い潰してくださいわかりました5年はかかるしてましたひょっとしたら
ドラゴンボールが現実世界にあった時ようにちょっと練習したいと思います今日は自分
の中でドラゴンボールを7つ
探すのも難しい雪をやっていると思います
食べてください箇所もじゃないっ
[音楽]
それで私のこの家の中にドラゴンボールが7個隠されております名著フールとしては
本当にこの家の中にあるらしいです
ななこただ隠した方にも超本気で隠したらしいので結構見つけるのが大変だと思うんで
ちょっと本気で今から探していこうと思いますいやっ実際の魂7個見つける飲む水金
ベッツどこの家の造りを説明しますと
しかし
玄関リビングお風呂場洗面所へ階段を登って何か御負極ある安らぎ部屋的なところで
ことで編集病となっております果たしてどこにあるんでしょうか
まずはこのちょっと安らぎ部屋から探していきましょうシンプルに普通にこの店の中に
隠してそうな気もするんだよなぁ
[音楽]
かわいいこのかでないってだけ
あれば1個3柄がうっ
普通に景気を知らないでしょ全く知らないですけどば万事でえっ
無理かこれない泥棒モールをした辞さずしかないんですってと思います
ベランダぽいなぁオナーズはベランダとみたぞ
国内あいつのことだから多分年半ばに隠してなります
なんではれ大洪水
山水画やは無理だ避難の中にこんなのが入ってるなんて知らなかったよいやこの部屋は
収納が多いでマッチャーですお願いしますねぇー
こういう多くとかねすぐよいやらしいあることが
ですやり感じるからドレスね
で1口3つかなんだよバッハ
山
ブーバー魂魄いつかにょアーマーぞ
ええええええ
がちなのね一個もないんだよ
ないないないないない5秒後の中とか
是去派
たいなぁこういうループの方がにあるフォン
出会い砂漠年末でんじゃねーよええ
ウチナーレクチャーします
[音楽]
えっ
黒出てきた昆布でえっなんでかもでぶつけやる手でもっぽいよねー
ポイポイ4きましたよごめんなさーなんでこんなことすんだよ
普通に追い撮りえっこれはー
1個目どれもボール見つけたと思ったらフェイクでした
どんな時間の無駄遣いだとなんか1個ぐらい掃除機簡単に見つかるんじゃないかと思っ
パースが全部難しいですね
一生懸命月までいきましょうちょっともう一回編集名産しますじゃないよ
いや悟空たちはいるけど a コールカーテンのさあ
スキーのとかなり九段下んですよやっぱいないんだよねマジでどこになったろう
ねえええ
[音楽]
たぶんこの英断の部屋はないんですが皆が探せないところがあるのかもしれないんです
けどパッと見たかってなんかそうよね
国松入んないから服の線はイヤーだめだしていきましょうよ
[音楽]
[拍手]
ブーブー d
これじゃないし楽しくいますねハッハー
ないよあげー冷蔵庫映像はそう
can ん
これやべーマジでねぇ本気なのか
じゃあ z 見つけるようよ
car
あっ本社バッター目で見てうわーこらー
こいつばっかじゃねーよあっ本線にいくねやって見つけましたーーー
パペペイネバカじゃねぇこいつマジで
[音楽]
me
バッハ
一戦の内部に隠しておりましたバナーのバーサー
こういう感じのはて前だろうねだろう
ええええええ
で怖いよ